- Il est évident maintenant
que le Parti libéral formera
- En 1970, Robert Bourassa,
pldu Québec de l'histoire,
est au pouvoir depuis quelques
mois quand éclate la crise
d'Octobre, les enlèvements
du FLQ et la Loi des mesuréeéeée
à Ottawa.ononononononononononons
avec le fédéral sur la
constitution e g g guerre
au front commun des syndicats,
dont il emprisonne les leaders.
Il navigue desesese en crise,
mais malgré tout, il demeure
très populaire.PIPIPIPIPIPIPIPI,
journaliste
- Les gens vivaient encore
la crainte des événements
dans le pays à partir de ça,
i i ils voulaient beaucoup
de stabilité. Il y avait tout ça
qui jouait en falililililililil.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Robert Bourassa veut
en profiter et convoque
pour le 29 octobre 1973,
pour surprendre les partis
d'opposition. Il y a le jeune
Pa
René Lévesque, non élu;
l'Union nationale deriririel
Loubier; et le Parti créditiste
d'Yvon Dupuis. Il veut p p p p .
- On a soupçonné les libéraux
de Monsieur Bourassa dururururuà
présenter des candidats un peu
partout, d'avoir espéré que
cette opposition du Parti
adverses et tout ça, et que
ça permette au Parti libéral
de l'emporter facilement.
(applaudissements)àààààààààààààr
de ma victoire.
- Le soir du 29 octobre,
le Parti libéral remporte
historique, du jamais-vu.
- Ce a a avait choqué,
ce soir-là, d'une façon,
c'était la réaction deasasasasa.
- Merci beaucoup à tous
mes collègues et à tous
mes collaborateurs.
froide, plutôt posée, plutôt
rationnelle, mais c'était pas
celui qui bondissait en l'air,
puis on
victoire historique, ce qui
était une victoire histoe.e.e.
- C'est évident que c'esananana,
quand vous êtes élu comme ça
avec 92 ou 95 % des députés,
mais le lendemain, c'est
♪ ♪ ♪
- Robert Bou
gourmand et il le regrette.
- Et au moment où on a réééé
les entrevues, je suis arrivé...
- Il expliquera son étrange
d'entrevues qu'il a accordées
à Raymond Saint-Pierre en 1977,
et rassemblées en grande partie
Bourassa".
Je me souviens quand j'avais
renc
qui était Premier ministre
britannique, aux funlllllles
de Monsieur Pompidou.
C'était quelques mois aprèsieien
m'avait dit, un peu en blaguant,
"mes sympathies".
Je dis : "pourquoi?"
serait trop faible.
On pourrait pas blâmer
l'opposition, par exemple,
empêché certains projets de loi
d'évoluer ou d'être créés.
C'est important pour lui d'avoir
une
québécois pour dire au reste
du pays : "Vous voyeààà,
il y a quand même une menace
au Québec. Faites attention,ncn,
faut repenser le pays".
Et là, bien en voyant que
le Parti québécois avait
évidemment, ça lui enlevait tout
un argumpopopour discuter avec
le reste du pays ou avec Ottawa
aussi.lilililililililililililil,
Robert Bourassa ajouté ceci :
"Et ce que
la campagne électorale de 1976,
c'est d'impliquer l'oppositi
dans le débat".
un monopole du gouvernement
et tout ça. C'est facile de...
après, d'accuser ce gouvernement
qu
besoin de faire des concessions.
Évidemment, on aiaiait
les accuser de corruption
et tout ça, puis ça, c'ests s st
de '76, évidemment.
- Doivent être au coeur
- En 1976, Robert Bourassafait s
qu'en 1973 : constitutionnelle,
linguistique
avec en prime l'hyperinflation
et une économie en difficulté.
verdict de la population qui...
- Faute d'une opposition solide,
les électeurs rendent Robert
Bour
de tous ces problèmes.
(cris de foule)
Et ils aiment être leur verdict.
- On l'espérait de tout notredas
comme ça cette année.
(cris de la foul